Voir d'un homme hostile à lutter contre les puissants pour que puisse triompher une certaine vision qu'il avait des choses.
En l'an 1466, un jeune Christophe de 15 ans est moussaillon sur un galion qui navigue au large des côtes d'Espagne.
En même année, une princesse de 16 ans, Isabelle, tirée de son couvent, débarque à la cour d'Espagne à Madrid où règne son frère Henri IV de Castille.
Laissez-moi vous présenter mes amis, mon noble allié, le marquis de Vilena et le frère de celui-ci, votre futur époux.
Vous l'avez sans doute compris, le monde d'Isabelle, pauvrement épieusement élevé et celui de son frère, roi débauché, n'étaient pas les mêmes.
Va-t-il arriver à cette pauvre princesse ?
Ne vous inquiétez pas, le sort va lui réserver une belle revanche.
Il arrive que le hasard fasse bien les choses, alors que Vilhena se rendait à la cérémonie du mariage.
Et oui, il était mort. Un fâche aux accidents, non ?
Ou pas pour tout le monde, et après tout, allez-donc savoir.
Deux ans plus tard, voilà que de nouveau on tire Isabelle du couvent de Ségovie, où on l'avait oublié.
Sœur, notre seigneur vient de rappeler à lui notre bien-aimé frère Alphonse.
Vous voici donc, héritière du trône, et la raison d'état veut que l'on vous marie sans tarder.
Faut y songer.
Quels sont les prétendants que vous me conseillez ?
Les prétendants, eh bien, voyons voir, réfléchissons un peu.
Il y a bien sûr votre cousin, le jeune Ferdinand d'Aragon,
mais il y a surtout Charles, le frère du roi de France.
Voilà une belle et bonne alliance.
Alors écoutez bien, votre confesseur, ma chère enfant, il n'est pas question d'épouser n'importe qui.
Je veux bien suivre vos conseils. Frère Pérez, informez-vous bien et revenez tout me dire sur ces princes.
Le prince Charles est triste comme un jour sans pain et maigre, si bien que quand il marche, ses os s'entrechoquent.
Mais votre noble cousin d'Aragon, quel bel homme, regardez, ne trouvez-vous pas gracieux ?
Et avec ça, de bonne manière, c'est l'époux qu'il vous faut.
Nous avons décidé que c'est le frère du roi de France que vous épouserez.
Monsieur, il n'en est pas question, c'est Ferdinand d'Aragon que j'épouserai.
La raison d'être un vœu, ma chère enfant, que vous épousiez Charles de France, le frère du roi.
Non, pardonnez-moi, sire, ma raison veut que j'ai plus ce qui me convient, et c'est ce que je ferai, voilà.
Petite impertinente, il n'en est pas question, vous entendez jamais !
Monseigneur, la princesse Isabelle est introuvable, elle s'est sauvée.
Qu'on la rattrape, qu'on l'arrête, qu'on l'emprisonne !
Au 1469 à Valladolid, l'archevêque de Tolède va donc unir Isabelle et Ferdinand d'Aragon.
Bruyant à venir les attend.
Bien sûr, le roi de France est furieux, Vilhena est furieux, le roi d'Espagne est furieux,
Mais, comme la colère est mauvaise conseillère,
Vilena va mourir.
Et Henri d'Espagne va en faire autant.
En 1474, Isabelle, 23 ans, Ferdinand, 22 ans,
monte sur le trône d'Espagne.
Ce sera le règne des rois catholiques.
Le jeune Christophe.
Ne sois pas si impatient, jeune homme.
Je vais te raconter.
Bien sûr, notre jeune ami a grandi lui aussi.
Et un jour, au large des côtes du Portugal,
pas très loin de Lisbonne,
son bateau est pris à partie par une escadre française.
Fais montre de courant.
Réalisme.
Il en a été nommé gouverneur.
C'était paisible mais un jour...
...a eu la bonne idée d'amener là un couple de lapins.
Viens changer notre...
C'est mon frère qui est devenu le gouverneur.
M'tit Diego...
Le jeune colon se plonge dans des études.
Recueille des indices qui le laissent sans jour.
Un jour j'ai ramassé une pièce de bois, une sorte de visage, de totem, je ne sais pas.
C'était pas sculpté avec une lame, c'était plus brut.
Bon, elle ne pouvait venir que de cette direction, que de là, que de l'ouest.
C'était une belle pièce.
Elle était très grande, au moins comme ça.
OOOOH!
Vincent, tu es là pour piloter le navire, pas pour parler, reprends la barre et vite !
Viens voir, Philippa, ce que j'ai reçu.
C'est la carte que Toscanelli a bien voulu m'envoyer.
Comme moi, il pense qu'il n'y a pas plus de 4000 km entre Lisbonne, Sipango, l'Asie.
Il pense qu'il y a là-bas de l'or en quantité, beaucoup d'épices et des âmes à convertir.
Arrêtez, mon cher Christophe. Je t'amène un navigateur et je pense que le rapport de cet homme va...
Je vais aller au Flandre. Malheureusement, une tempête nous a déportés vers l'ouest.
On ne savait plus où on était.
Toujours le vent retombe, et nous voilà près d'une île.
Et là, sur le rivage, des gens bizarres, comme nous qui nous regardent, nous font des signes.
Malgré tout, vous comprenez, on a préféré prendre une autre direction, c'était plus raisonnable.
Mais il y a sûrement d'autres gens à connaître, et de nouvelles terres à découvrir, un nouveau continent peut-être.
Alonso de Huelva dit vrai.
Faut y aller.
Il le faut absolument.
Prouverait le moyen.
Un nouveau monarque, Jean, siège au Portugal et devant sa cour, notre ami Colón expose ses plans, ses certitudes.
Mais nous avons déjà vu ce document, c'est Oscanelli qui nous a soumis cette carte.
C'est Oscanelli, ce petit médecin venu de Florence, plus versé dans les sciences que dans la navigation.
Tout de même si nous ne pourrions pas profiter de ce document pour favoriser la circulation vers l'ouest de nos vaisseaux.
Mais cher Colón, dites-nous, quelles seraient vos conditions si l'on vous chargeait d'une expédition vers ces terres inconnues ?
Alors, jeune homme, dites-nous, quelles seraient vos conditions ?
Le titre d'amiral des océans, la vice-royauté, le gouvernement des terres découvertes et le dixième des prises, des éperons d'or.
L'impertinent, quelle odeur, ces petits énormes, eh !
Eh bien, ils ont ri. Oh, si tu savais, comme ils se sont moqués.
Dors, un fer jusqu'à la cour d'Espagne.
Mon frère, soyez bon, je ne vous demande qu'un peu de pain et d'eau pour mon fils.
Vous ferez aussi bien de passer la nuit ici, la région n'est pas sûre.
Et puis, nos révérends pères seront sûrement très intéressés par votre récit.
Restez, votre histoire les passionnera.
Nous connaissons nous aussi l'imagomundi du cardinal Dehi, dont vous vous faites l'enthousiaste interprète et Aristote, auteur des grands traités,
Lucius Sénèque ainsi que le physicien Poséidonios, qui sont de bien nobles précurseurs.
Mais j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'en pense notre savant père de la Marchena.
Il est bien possible qu'il existe à l'ouest de grandes terres habitées,
et même si les connaissances de notre bouillonnante amie me semblent sujettes à caution,
constatons qu'ils possèdent de l'enthousiasme, et surtout l'autre assez indispensable pour réussir.
Et pour cela, révérend Père Péresse, nous devons l'aider.
Christophe, mon ami de Talavera, un personnage éminent à la cour,
m'informe par cette missive que la reine accepte de me recevoir à Cordoue.
Dieu vous garde.
Un sainte lieu.
Une semaine de marche sépare où elle va de Cordoue.
Vous nous avez sauvé la vie.
Vous avez toute ma reconnaissance.
Je me nomme Pedro de Arrénia et cette jeune fille que ces malfrats voulaient enlever,
c'est Béatrice, ma jeune sœur.
Tant qu'à d'être votre nom.
Colomb, Christophe, découvrir des terres nouvelles,
Là-bas, il y a de l'or, des pierres précieuses, toutes ces richesses qui sont encore ignorées de tous.
Vous êtes venu pour voir la reine, mais vous ne saviez pas que toute la cour a quitté Cordoue pour passer l'hiver à Madrid.
Ils ne reviendront qu'au printemps.
Vous devriez écrire à leur majesté et attendre ici avec nous que le printemps revienne.
J'ai la réponse. Leur majesté vont me recevoir.
Lignez d'accepter ma requête. Je vous en rendrai grâce, majesté.
Majesté, c'est courtisant, il y a toujours quelque chose à qui m'ont rendu.
Cardinal, n'est-ce pas le seigneur Colomb qui s'avance ?
Vous êtes Christophe Colomb, je suppose, et est recommandé par l'archevêque.
Eh bien, je vous promets, monsieur de Talavera, que nous allons écouter avec beaucoup d'attention votre protégé.
Gracieuse Majesté, permettez que je vous montre cette carte.
Mes connaissances, mes expériences démontrent que l'on peut se rendre à Cathay et à la cour de Chine bien plus rapidement par l'ouest que par l'est.
Il appartient, vos gracieuses majestés catholiques, de reprendre contact avec l'empereur Asiatique et de nouer alliance avec lui.
Cela ferait une formidable confédération de pâtes.
Nos adversaires musulmans se trouveraient balayés et puis il y a toutes ces âmes par millions à gagner pour l'église du Christ.
Sans compter toutes les richesses, l'or et les diamants dont parlait déjà Marco.
Moi, comment connaissez-vous l'existence de ces terres d'Océanie ? Vous en parlez comme si vous y étiez allé.
Excellence, voilà bien des années que j'étudie la question et tout m'en apporte la certitude.
Mon garçon, que demanderiez-vous alors, Majesté, en échange de vos découvertes ?
La dignité d'amiral, la viceroyauté, le gouvernement des îles et de toutes les terres découvertes.
Je revendique aussi la dixième partie des biens et richesses trouvés.
Ainsi parla Colomb.
Et alors, qu'est-ce qu'ils ont dit, les rois ?
Il était gonflé, ce Colomb.
Je trouve qu'il avait bien raison.
Je suis de votre avis, les enfants, moi aussi, je le trouve gonflé.
Et surtout, il jouait gros.
Le roi décida de soumettre le plan de Colomb à une commission,
car il avait en tête bien d'autres soucis.
Il rêvait de la reconquête de Grenade,
mais d'abord, il fallait reprendre Malaga.
La ville était encerclée et on attendait patiemment qu'elle se rende.
Vous gardez vos positions.
La famille sera renvoyée de commission en commission.
Ce fut la chute de Malaga.
Noble sire, toutes ces convocations, nous tournons en rond.
Alors que de fabuleuses richesses nous attendent.
Si elles existent vraiment, qu'est-ce qui nous prouve que ces terres n'appartiennent à personne ?
Aucun fait n'en témoigne.
Mais plus de dix fois, je vous ai donné mes raisons.
Votre projet n'a pas de base assez solide pour que l'Espagne engage sa renommée et la vie de ses sujets.
Votre plan est rejeté.
Alors partons pour la France. Il y a là-bas un roi qu'on dit intelligent.
Ici, il n'y a que des imbéciles, des ânes, oui, alors que je leur apporte le monde et ses trésors et c'est comme ça qu'on me traite.
Calmez-vous mon jeune ami. Je vais voir personnellement la reine et plaider votre cause.
Après tout, j'ai toujours été son confident. Surtout attendez que je revienne, promettez-le moi.
Jamais j'ai vu mon père aussi furieux et crier aussi fort. Jamais il a été dans une telle colère.
Tu crois qu'il serait possible que je parte avec lui pour le grand voyage ?
Allez, allez, vite, plus vite, il n'y a pas un instant à perdre.
Vite, vite, il n'y a pas un instant à perdre, vite, les souverains vous attendent.
Dépêchez-vous, ils vont quitter Cordoue pour Grenade.
Qui doit être lavé, cette nuit vous viendrez avec nous.
En étant dangereux, protégeons-la.
Je vais par là avec mes hommes.
Espérez-vous de cette expédition alors que Nicolas de Lyra et Saint-Augustin peuvent être habités ?
Comment le serait-il ? Il faudrait que les gens y vivent la tête en bas, c'est très...
L'Ira et Saint-Augustin ont été de grands théologiens grâce leur soir-rendu, mais assurément, ils n'étaient pas cosmographes, car les navires portugais qui sillonnent les mers lointaines, la tête en bas, démontraient tous les jours que leurs opinions n'étaient aucune mo...
Absurde, ai-je entendu tout à l'heure ? Mais ce qui serait absurde, vous en conviendrez, j'en suis sûr, c'est qu'après avoir créé le monde, notre Seigneur en ait laissé la majeure partie inutile, vide d'homme, et si elle ne l'est pas, ce que je crois, il vous appartient à vous tous et à nos majestés catholiques d'aider à y apporter l'évangile.
Et si nous tombons d'accord pour le projet, quelle récompense souhaitez-vous ?
Toujours la même, votre éminence, tout d'abord la dignité d'amiral, la vice-royauté,
ensuite le gouvernement des terres découvertes et à découvrir,
et aussi la dixième partie des biens et richesses qui seront trouvées.
Silence, c'est bien, la commission va réfléchir et avisera.
Et Grenade à son tour tombe.
Entre les vôtres qui souhaitent demeurer à Grenade, ils pourront le faire.
Les mosquées resteront ouvertes et le culte assuré.
Ils conserveront leurs biens et seront libres de leurs occupations.
Quant à vos augustes cires, nos magnanimes majestés catholiques ont décidé de vous laisser une terre dans les Alpajouras,
où vous pourrez à votre guise poursuivre vos occupations.
Fais-ce comme une femme ce royaume que tu n'as pas à se défendre comme un homme.
Laissez-moi passer !
Tu ne le penses ?
Votre jeune ami avait la décision de la commission en poche.
Rien n'était bien fameux dans tout ça.
Alors, mais quand est-ce qu'il va la découvrir, l'Amérique ?
Vous allez voir ce que vous allez voir.
Ne perdons pas de courage.
Notre ami Zorro va arriver.
Alors mon ami, ça ne va pas ?
C'est de vous informer que votre demande ne peut être acceptée ?
Signé Pérez Almazone ?
Pérez Almazone, Pérez Almazone, le vieil garde, la vieille mule !
Il va avoir mes nouvelles celui-là !
Courage Cristobal, je prends l'affaire en main !
Oh mais on va voir ce qu'on va voir !
À quoi bon mon bon ami, je vous assure, j'en ai assez, vraiment assez.
La fatigue me gagne, c'est décidé, je pars.
À nous de jouer !
Majesté Majesté, vous dont j'ai toujours été résolu, voilà que vous en manquez !
Comment pouvez-vous laisser l'obscurantisme, les manigances, avoir raison de mon ami Colom
alors qu'il s'agit d'une entreprise fantastique où il y a peu de risques et tant de profits possibles pour la couronne,
pour la gloire de notre Seigneur et de notre Église, de notre pays ?
Pardonnez ma hardiesse, mais Majesté, je ne vous reconnais plus !
En tant que financier et conseiller royal, permettez Majesté de m'exprimer.
Majesté, il serait grand dommage que quelque autre royaume bénéficie de ces découvertes si elles ont lieu.
Si vous le souhaitez, je pourrais avancer les fonds nécessaires à l'entreprise.
On peut faire confiance à ce jeune homme.
Juan de Colonna, veuillez prendre note.
Établissez le contrat convenu, la dignité d'amiral, la vice-royauté,
le gouvernement des îles, des terres découvertes et de celles qui restent à découvrir.
On a bien dit qui restent à découvrir.